hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
laboratory testing for viral hepatitis
what's new and what has changed i'm
sabrina lamos of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by diasporin
to learn more you can visit diasoren.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question
box and click send any questions
submitted today will be answered via
email
following the broadcast if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located on the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr robert
gish
a young professor of medicine at the
university of nevada schools of medicine
in las vegas and in reno for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr gish you may now begin your
presentation
greetings thank you for joining us today
this is about stopping hepatitis
in celebration of world hepatitis day
july 28
2020 laboratory testing for viral
hepatitis
what's new and what has changed i'm dr
robert gish
based in san diego i teach a number of
other institutions including loma linda
and university of california san diego
our agenda today viral hepatitis
overview and guidelines updates
focusing on hepatitis c and hepatitis b
within hepatitis b we'll be looking at
serology
disease state hepatitis b e antigen and
e antibody
and also talking specifically about
hepatitis b surface antigen
what is the status of hepatitis b and c
in the u.s today
well this is looking back a little bit
and also we're going to talk about
looking forward
there is a goal for elimination of
hepatitis b and c in the us
by 2030 but we're not really on target
unfortunately
you can see with a little red x mark on
the right side that we have
increasing acute hepatitis b infections
as we're seeing with hepatitis c
infections this is because of the opioid
epidemic
and problems with implementing effective
harm reduction
we are decreasing the rate of hepatitis
c related deaths and hepatitis b
related deaths because we have more
active testing
and more linkage to care
hepatitis guidelines these are from the
cdc
in alignment with aasld and the u.s
preventative health services task force
what about hepatitis c this is curable
but there's no vaccine but it's also
preventable with harm reduction
and a clean blood supply our updated
guidelines now are
to test all adults all
pregnancies for hepatitis c at risk
individuals
so we're still taking a risk history and
in at-risk individuals
we'd be testing basically annually
hepatitis b is vaccine preventable but
not curable
but we can suppress hepatitis b and
change
outcomes decreasing death liver
transplant
liver cancer liver failure and
importantly with both hepatitis b and c
as infectious diseases we're going to be
decreasing
transmission by testing and linkage to
care
the institute of medicine started
talking about changing outcomes in 2010
advocating for screening for viral
hepatitis to be part
of the primary care provider assessment
algorithm
and at risk individuals now
test all adults foresee hepatitis b
is not quite as general although the
hepatitis b foundation where i work
is advocating that all adults be tested
for hepatitis b
using the triple hepatitis b panel we'll
talk about that in a moment
we have very effective vaccines and in
fact we have a two dose vaccine
that is at time zero and time one month
with a much higher antibody response
rate and with two doses better
compliance
that's very important thinking about
these corona times
and minimizing the number of times some
individual needs to come to clinic
by decreasing transmission will have
fewer carriers and fewer
onward transmission of viral hepatitis b
and c gaps exist
fortunately over the last two decades
we've become very good at testing for
hiv
and linking to care hepatitis c and b as
you can see
in these big circles these venn diagrams
is we have prevalence data but diagnosis
and treatment to care a marked decrease
or a marked
lack of those two next steps
so let's get on board with the who
efforts
our own national efforts international
programs
of testing screening and linkage to care
let's talk about an update on hepatitis
c we still have a lot of work to do
treatments are available but fortunately
the cost has come down
to about 20 to 30 000 per cure which is
absolutely amazing
this is not only cost effective this is
cost
savings but we have this problem of
increasing number of hepatitis c
acute infections and subsequent chronic
disease
we need to be preventing those but
testing and treating
even acute hepatitis c the reduction
needed to meet a 2020 goal where we're
sitting today is 76
and we're not there but we're going to
be getting there i think over the next
decade
with everybody's help
why test for hepatitis b well
this is a very serious problem worldwide
two people
die every minute from complications of
hepatitis b cirrhosis
and liver cancer we don't have enough
liver transplants to go around
we can prevent b with a vaccine and we
can treat people who are chronically
infected
by suppressing virus not curing the
disease although sometimes we use the
word
functional cure just think about this a
million people
dying every it's time to test
and link people to care
a little bit more on hepatitis b testing
the preventative health services task
force high risk screening
increased risk screening they may be
modifying their recommendations to test
all adults in 2021
i definitely hope so how do we get to
elimination if we're not testing
everybody
and we don't just test with a single
test we need a triple
panel i'll describe that triple panel in
just a moment
our hepatitis b foundation has been
advocating for years to test all adults
and in fact we have an interesting
new method of communication called
know your abcs know your hepatitis a
b and c status you could even say with
that
c could have two c's which is the
coronavirus
risk-based testing is not efficient
we've proven that over the years
that's why they went to testing all
adults for hiv
and now all adults for hepatitis c we
should be doing the same
for hepatitis b more to come
tests used to screen for hepatitis b as
indicated here
is this triple panel hepatitis b surface
antigen
indicates infection linkage to care
core antibody equals exposure
this is a very specific test with a
false
positive rate of only two per thousand
so if you seek core antibody
you know exposure you know that patient
has ccc dna in their liver
even after acute disease people in clear
surface antigen
ccc dna remains according to research in
peer-reviewed publications
anti-hbs indicates immunity if
core antibody and surface antigen are
negative
there is no such thing as natural
immunity we need to get that term
out of our lexicon once you're exposed
and infected
like many other dna viruses that virus
persists in almost every single patient
i am hopeful for a cure someday because
we have all sorts of new technology
but i think that's about a decade away
to be able to get rid of ccc dna
and even the integrated virus isolated
core antibody positivity
could indicate a cold hepatitis b and in
those patients
we think about testing for hbv dna
using current epidemiologic
terminology in the us surface antigen
positive equals infection
hbv dna positive equals infection
even if surface antigens negative and
that is current and state of the art
the core igm antibody
is seen at high tide or an acute disease
that could be seen at low tide
and chronic disease with flares so
sometimes we
make mistakes with that test
interpretation
it would be nice if we had antibody
titers when core igm
was reported these patients who core
antibody positive
alone do not need hepatitis b
vaccination there are no peer reviewed
publications that show a clinical
benefit
of boosting trying to get surface
antibody
up increase positive in this patient
population
this is a nice graphic about natural
history of hepatitis b
and where we're thinking about treatment
it's pretty simple now
we're treating most people replication
hpv dna quantification if it's over 2
000
we're thinking about treating alt above
25 in women
above 35 and men we're thinking about
treatment
we also assess for fibrosis in our
patients we can do that with
non-invasive tests today
apri fib 4 fiber scan other tools
increased fibrosis also we're thinking
strongly about treatment
so now we're turning things around and
saying why should we
not treat what patient population should
not be seeing
an antiviral agent and that's relatively
few
if the patient's replicating especially
with the enzymes
being even at the upper limits of normal
so think about these phases
this is very important to know about the
natural history
and think about how hepatitis b evolves
this is a very important slide that
brings up to us
new terminology these are the new easel
terms that i find
very attractive and what i apply in my
practice
if somebody has a normal alt but high
dna
we're going to call that chronic
infection we used to call it immune
tolerant but we're not using that term
anymore
e antigen positive with elevated liver
enzymes
elevated dna chronic hepatitis
next phase they lose the antigen dna
falls somewhat but alt also goes back
into that healthy range that we talked
about
back to chronic infection then we have a
knee antigen negative phase with more
active disease elevated alt
dna still positive chronic hepatitis
i really believe these are the most
useful ways
of putting our patients in specific
categories
let's now talk about perinatal hpv
transmission
mother-to-child transmission is
responsible for one-third of all
hpv infections worldwide in our country
we should be down to zero but there's
about a thousand cases a year
of babies acquiring hepatitis b from
their mothers and being chronically
infected
the higher the dna level in the mother
the higher the risk
the e-antigen positive higher risk
higher surface antigen levels
higher risk surface antigen mutants
allow the virus to escape vaccine
stimulated immunity
passive immunity through hepatitis b
immune globulin administration
so we need to make sure that our
hepatitis b tests are sensitive and able
to detect
these surface antigen mutants these
surface antigen mutants can also explain
obi a cult hepatitis b infection that we
talked about earlier
system failures mothers aren't tested
high-risk mothers are not
offered anti-viral treatment if their
viral loads over two hundred thousand
during the third trimester
if infants don't receive vaccination
they say within the first 24 hours in
the guidelines then within 12 hours
a recent study that was performed in
thailand suggested that
if we give the baby the vaccine within
two hours of birth
we might not even need an antiviral
therapy for the mother
who has high viral load hbig
is expensive it's also another injection
may be missed in terms of administration
early vaccination may decrease
the need for hbig administration as well
babies born to surface energy and others
should be tested between 6 and 18 months
after delivery to see what their
hepatitis b status is
prevalence of chronic hepatitis b in the
u.s
really the number we think about is 2.2
million
and here are special populations people
who inject drugs
homeless veterans hiv or hepatitis c
infections looking for co-infections we
discussed
newborns more into surface antigen
positive mothers
department of corrections incarcerated
individuals
history of incarceration health care
professionals of course
also need to be assessed
prevalence of chronic hepatitis b in the
us is outlined here we're going to use
the number 2.2 million for the moment
what we show here on this left and right
graph
left is the general right asia pacific
islanders
is a small number of individuals both
with known meaning tested for hepatitis
b
diagnosed in receiving treatment we
think that any given time only about a
hundred thousand individuals
are on treatment for their hepatitis b
with a nucleus side
or nucleotide analog we think that
number should be much higher
we think about replication fibrosis
or elevated liver enzymes
hepatitis b impact is highlighted here
the impact of hepatitis b is further
detailed on this slide
you think about this evolution to
cirrhosis or liver cancer
i described to my patients their
lifetime risk of cirrhosis
ranges from 15 to 40 percent
higher for men than women same for liver
cancer
give a general number about seven
percent but it could be as high as 15
percent
and men three to four percent in women
hepatitis b can go through reactivation
compensated cirrhosis decompensated
cirrhosis by treating
decompensated cirrhosis with nucleoside
or nucleotide analogs you can often
reverse
their function the decompensation and
sometimes you can take
cirrhosis backwards to a non-serotic
state
of course we're very concerned about
patients dying or needing liver
transplants
for hepatitis b
e antigen and the antibody help describe
what phase of disease that patient is in
earlier phase is called a wild-type
virus
and later through mutations and immune
pressure
there are core and stop codons stop
mutations where e antigen levels
fall may disappear not being measured
directly
and dna levels can fall slightly but the
dna and virus replication may be ongoing
this disease the e antigen negative
disease is a little harder to treat in
the sense that the chance of surface
antigen loss
that term functional cure is less likely
to happen with nucleoside or nucleotide
analogues
we're approaching both populations with
our newer therapies that are in research
right now
both disease phases stages are very
important to understand
and very important to treat
hepatitis b surface engine is expressed
by a moderately conserved region of the
hepatitis b genome
we say moderately conserved that means
that that area can change
mutate and make antigen surface antigen
that we don't detect
with our standard antibody to antigen
test kits so when we are developing
tests
commercializing bringing tests to clinic
we need to make sure our test
is broad base it can detect as many of
these s antigen variants
as possible because we want to know
accurately
our patient's hepatitis b status
need to know that in terms of
vaccination maybe even help us
in terms of developing new vaccines
later in the future of case we have
these escape mutations and they become
clinically important
the innate and adaptive immune response
is very important for both acute and
chronic hepatitis b
we use this term now immune control we
use it in two different ways
one is very good immune control happens
when the dna is lower
s antigen is falling e antigen may be
clearing
we also use the word immune control when
we find a patient
to be core antibody positive and surface
antibody positive
but surface antigen's negative this
immune control means a more
active robust immune system keeping
viral replication
to the lowest level possible that immune
control
typically means a better prognosis a
lower risk of progression to cirrhosis
cancer transplant and death
i'm now going to walk through some
comparisons
about mutations between acute liver
failure and those with chronic hepatitis
v
there are several mutations in this mhr
region including this y134 and p120 that
have been described to lead to the
emergence of escape mutants
this has been seen also with monoclonal
antibody treatment
this is in a special setting of immune
suppressed patients
after liver transplant and these immune
variants
became very replication competent and
actually led to liver failure in some
patients
it's also been described with hiv
hepatitis b co-infection so when the
immune system has
less immune surveillance these mutants
can also undergo immune escape
this may explain some vaccine failure
cases
some immune globulin failures and
failures of
assay detection of surface antigen
this mutation process may be more
relevant in liver cancer
liver cancer cirrhosis cases than in
asymptomatic or pre-serotic
individuals this is also published by
zhang and chinese patients
as well as coppola this was
significantly detected
more in hcc cirrhotic than asymptomatic
or pre-serratic individuals
they then looked at acute liver failure
specifically
in the acute liver failure population
there is significantly higher mutation
frequency in this a
determinant than in chronic hepatitis b
these mutations are genotype specific
and occur at a higher frequency in the
major hydrophilic region and are
associated with higher viral loads
and lower anti-core igm titers
this acute liver failure coexistence
with anti-hbs can be seen so
some patients have surface angine and
surface antibody
we sometimes can explain that by these s
antigen mutants where the antibody that
is present
isn't binding the surface antigen
outcomes do not necessarily differ
between the groups without
mutations in terms of some specific
clinical outcomes
this is comparison of mutations between
the acute liver failure subjects those
with chronic hepatitis b
this is the acute liver failure study
group registry
mutations are highlighted below 62
of chronic hepatitis b patients and 76
percent
of hepatitis b alf patients
let's now wrap up with some conclusions
hepatitis b and hepatitis c
are prevalent in the us and major health
care problems
actually resulting in more deaths than
hiv
malaria and tb hepatitis b virology is
complicated the immune interaction with
the virus is also complicated
e-antigen and the antibodies are markers
of phases of the disease and important
for monitoring patients
natural history and on treatment
hepatitis b surface antigen
is definitely the most important marker
because we need to assess
infection status infectivity status
need to link to care we've had lots of
clarity on core antibody and surface
antibody as well we need to make sure
our tests
are highly sensitive and can detect
patients with s antigen
even if they carry excess
antigen-related mutations
thank you for joining us today this
important presentation
thank you again dr gish for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lap roots and
our sponsor diasoren
for underwriting today's educational
webcasts
before i go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of your registration
the webcast can also be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye